donc les harceleur ils sont toujours
bien tranquille à l'école oui sanction
aucune sanction donc aujourd'hui et vous
qu'est-ce qui se passe donc moi j'ai
refusé de de le laisser d'installer dans
cette établissement c'était hors de
question donc j'ai mon proposé de le
changer donc c'est moi qui ai pris
l'initiative de le changer de
d'établissement
sauf que bon après le nouvel
établissement sont très bien il y a pas
de il y a pas de souci sauf que Farès il
en faut bus scolaire il y a même un jour
il s'est caché dans l'établissement donc
ils ont cherché partout
donc là il veut plus retourner parce
qu'il vient d'apprendre que un de ces
harceleurs
va venir dans l'établissement de Farès
comme il déménage et que ça va être son
collège de secteur donc il va être mis
dans ce collège c'est la folie alors
c'est
la folie vous avez été contacté par
l'ancien collège depuis ou pas non
aucune nouvelle aucune nouvelle donc ils
sont débarrassées ils sont ni non tant
pis on passe à autre chose terminé et
donc comme vous l'avez dit les
harceleurs de Farès jamais été
sanctionnés par établissement non pas du
tout tranquille et donc là il y a il y a
un des harceleurs qui va venir dans le
nouveau collège c'est ça et tranquille
vous avez
dit aux nouveaux chefs d'établissement
que cette personne avait reçu votre fixe
non parce que ça reste s'il veut plus
retourner d'accord je vais le regarder
avec moi la maison donc ma seule
solution c'est de faire mais vous pouvez
pas dire au chef d'établissement qu'il
faut pas que cet élève et c'est pas le
chef d'établissement qui va prendre la
décision c'est l'Académie et vu que j'ai
l'Académie ne me prend pas au téléphone
donc l'Académie elle vous a jamais pris
téléphone non non on a l'impression que
dans l'éducation nationale c'est une
mafia je vous jure que c'est vrai que
tout le monde se tient tout le monde
tout le monde se tient nos mères pas
terrible c'est et on a l'impression
vraiment que on ne peut rien faire qui
c'est c'est une petite mafia et ils font
ce qu'ils veulent et ils décident ce
qu'ils veulent et ils essaient ils se
tiennent les uns les autres il y a pas
d'autorité au-dessus se tiennent les uns
les autres chacun fait son truc et
plutôt que de s'en prendre harceleur et
bien les établissements disent mais non
chez nous il se passe rien il y a rien
limite c'est de la faute de celui qui a
été harcelé qui peut-être convoqué c'est
hallucinant et puis il essaie toujours
de faire ça comme ça au moins il se
débarrasse des problèmes et ils ont pas
des mauvaises notes c'est comme la
médiatisation c'est un prétexte
totalement débile justement on va en
parler dans un instant donc c'est faux
vous avez des nouvelles de l'enquête ou
pas oui alors mon avocate a fait la
demande d'avoir accès au dossier et aux
expertises médicales qui a été refusé
par la procureur de Carcassonne d'accord
au dossier pourquoi
ce qui se dit en amont c'est que ils ont
pas aimé la médiatisation exactement
alors il paraît que ce serait pour punir
les parents de la mise à la
médiatisation de l'affaire et de leur
présence régulière sur les réseaux
sociaux
non seulement l'éducation nationale qui
ne fait rien et maintenant la justice
qui est elle-même n'en quête pas parce
que c'est vrai que l'enquête n'avance
pas au début il y a une vingtaine
d'auditions et depuis je sais pas si
vous avez d'autres infos mais moi celle
que j'ai c'est qu'il y a rien qui avance
il y a plus d'audition parce qu'on vous
dit oui alors vous avez parlé donc la la
justice dans l'Aude dit ça va nous
retomber dessus on va avoir une mauvaise
image qui se préoccupe de leur image
alors qu'il y a l'avenir d'un enfant qui
est en jeu c'est hallucinant Cyril il
faut que ça change c'est complètement
hypocrite parce qu'en public il se sert
de cette médiatisation pour faire le
petit communiqué le petit truc qui va
bien et en off il vous le reproche
quasiment et ça devient vous quasiment
les coupables en fait et c'est horrible
de faire ça donc cette médiatisation au
final il faut s'en servir pour faire
bouger les choses et oui ils font rien à
part communiquer dans le vent c'est
c'est débile
Ahmed tu dois être comme un fou
[Musique]
on est foot ce cet enfant on va pas le
laisser comme ça à la maison et laisser
se faire emmerder et que ce soit lui en
plus qui soit pénalisé
en fait ou bien ils attendent qu'une
chose ils attendent ils disent ils vont
se calmer et puis on les fait la faire
va être étouffé et puis on va passer à
autre chose ou un nouvel élément machin
quoi c'est à dire ils attendent quoi
faudrait que soit ça reste se refasse
harceler ou qui est une nouvelle
émission que donc là pour l'instant ils
disent ouais on s'est fini il a fait
rien avec l'autre on passe à autre chose
quand je lui dis viens on sort à prendre
les rives pas dimanche on lui a proposé
d'aller faire du buggy ou pas
il reste dans sa chambre son monde c'est
sa chambre et manger
voilà niveau du quoi ben lui surtout la
il a peur de l'harceleur il a vraiment
peur et il me demande pourquoi ils sont
pas finis
et ça ça a une fois de plus je le dis et
c'est
un moment si rien ne se passe je vous
dis c'est ça le problème c'est qu'il y a
plein de gens aujourd'hui il faut pas le
faire je le redis qui se font justice
eux-mêmes à un moment tu deviens fou tu
vois ton fils qui est dans ta chambre et
qui a peur de d'aller voir un harceleur
parce qu'il est Raymond tu es d'accord
avec moi oui mais il faut il faut
surtout pas le faire parce que c'est
après c'est révers bien sûr si vous
faites une connerie après c'est savoir
tomber sur vous et sur Farès et ça va
être vous les méchant mais on comprend
vraiment c'est terrible c'est terrible
que ce soit lui maintenant qu'il soit
dans sa chambre et qui reste dans sa
chambre qui va être enfermé et qui fait
rien qui sort plus qui qui a une
personne de l'éducation nationale qui
est dedans qui me dit qui est vraiment
vraiment qui me dit l'éducation
nationale est une vraie mafia omerta
intimidation menace même envers certains
personnels qui parlent trop et c'est
vrai que c'est ce qu'on constate c'est
un truc de fou les établissements se
protègent pour avoir de bonnes notes de
bon de bons rapports de bons avis
maintenant ça compte pour eux donc du
coup ils ne font rien ils préfèrent
taire et
pour que lui n'a pas fait c'est à dire
que je vais au travail bah bravo bravo
elle mais si demain moi je fais un
travail et qu'un autre mec bien sûr on
travaille j'ai une pure j'ai plus rien à
faire à mon travail ça sert à rien que
je reste là en fait d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs vous avez contacté Brigitte
Macron oui j'ai écrit un courrier à
l'Élysée d'accord aussi à monsieur le
Président de la République d'accord je
tags tous les jours monsieur parce que
je sais qu'il passe partout
nationale de vraiment porter des
réponses mais plus ministre du
pique-nique il fait beau là il fait beau
là
c'est pas la bonne personne
il y a peut-être une disposition à toute
bête à mettre en place quand on est
ministre de l'éducation nationale c'est
simplement mettre dans chaque collège
chaque établissement une charte que s'il
les parents et que s'il les enfants et à
un moment si on se retrouve à être pris
à harceler on est viré alors le problème
c'est la sectorisation en fait le
problème c'est le rectorat c'est à dire
que après ces gosses pour ça qu'il faut
une
propositions
qu'il faut responsables
dans certaines écoles par exemple
privées c'est ce qui se passe voilà donc
tu signes et l'enfant aussi c'est que
s'il est pris voilà à harceler un petit
copain et ça fait partie des priorités
de l'école il est dégagé
le procureur la procureur donc a décidé
de classer l'affaire sans suite sur les
anciens harceleurs enfin les harceleurs
ceux qui ont harcelé votre fils dans
l'ancien établissement classé sans suite
mais là c'est le but de refuser l'accès
donc j'ai même pas accès aux expertises
médicales donc je sais même pas ce qui a
été noté dedans parce que je rappelle
qu'il vous avait été reproché la
médiatisation de et leur présence
régulière sur les réseaux sociaux donc
en fait il aurait fallu que vous ne
disiez rien c'est ça et que vous
laissiez vous partiez avec votre fils
dans un autre établissement et que vous
laissiez les recevoir tranquille on a
pas parlé parce que ça nous faisait
plaisir on a parlé parce que le
directeur ne faisait rien parce que là
ce non plus et que c'était un langage de
sourd avec eux et Gilles tu peux nous
dire ce qu'il en est de la faire s'il te
plaît oui donc une enquête avait été la
famille apporter plein d'une enquête a
été ouverte par le parquet de
Carcassonne pour harcèlement très
rapidement donc 20 personnes sont
auditionnées on a l'impression que ça
bouge il faut dire que à ce moment-là
Farès et non seulement harcelé mais
blessé poussé dans l'escalier on voit
ses blessures notamment ici avec vous
Cyril à l'antenne ça semble s'accélérer
et plus rien inertie totale rien
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas encore classé
sans suite mais ça s'achemine vers un
délitement comme on dit c'est comme si
on voulait enterrer la faire on va on va
pas se cacher les mots on va pas faire
de langue de bois c'est comme si la
justice n'avait pas envie d'aller au
bout de cette affaire soit par
un manque de volonté soit parce que
finalement dans l'Aude notamment à
Carcassonne on n'a pas envie de mettre
en difficulté ce collège on a envie que
rien de change donc c'est terrible pour
les parents et pour Farès voilà inertie
totale totale moi je vais vous dire
au-delà de ils ont pas ils ont pas de
cœur ces gens non mais ils sont chargés
un moment les mecs ils disent quoi ils
pensent qu'à leur gueule non mais c'est
les parents des harceleurs
ils ont pas de cœur aussi parce que
enfin pardon mais on n'est pas aussi et
je sais pas c'est incroyable que
personne ne vous appelle ou s'excuse il
y a des drames tous les jours les
enfants qui se suicident etc et ça fait
même pas avancer les enfants qu'on peut
sauver encore on essaye pas de les
sauver non mais je vous les laisse alors
sort quoi c'est devenu maintenant
tranquille il y a des enfants qui
suicident
12 ans après c'est pas mal non mais
c'est c'est normal non mais là la charte
dont parlait Sophie tout à l'heure c'est
peut-être responsabiliser les parents
quand tu as un gamin de 11 12 ans tu le
sais pas peut-être toi en tant que
parents que ton gamin de 11 12 ans il
est en train de faire du mal à l'école
ils sont quatre cinq sur un gars toi tu
rentres du boulot tu peux pas savoir ton
ton enfant de 11 ans il a fait des
conneries c'est peut-être ça quand le
directeur se tait ne dit rien il
convoque même pas les parents sur les
affaires qu'on avait avant peut-être ça
qu'il faut mettre en place de dire
maintenant qui a été Élisabeth borne qui
au Parlement envisage à l'Assemblée
envisage envisager mais d'exclure les
harceleurs et que ce serait un vrai loi
là au moins il y aurait quelque chose
d'éducation encore Twitter aujourd'hui
ah c'est bien alors ce n'est pas une
promesse ce sont des actes j'ai réuni
cet après-midi les recettes pour leur
donner ses directives prévenir détecter
prendre en charge le harcèlement c'est
notre mission et nous l'assurons sans
relâche pour prévenir les drames
apporter des solutions
il s'est fait sérieusement danser pour
son immobilisme là les femmes
s'accumulent il ne fait rien ben oui
pour que Madame borne aille en première
ligne et que le lui ensuite réunissent
les recteurs ça montre qu'on lui a dit
et là on ne fait rien alors on l'a
invité ce soir papa Ndiaye on a pas eu
de réponse
il a reçu les parents de la petite ligne
c'est et les parents étaient encore plus
énervé en sortant avec le
ministrement ils étaient quand ils sont
sortis de l'entretien avec le ministre
énervé tes parents
c'est ça qui est dans ils ont dit bah
les mec c'est catastrophique aucune
solution
une solution donc ça veut dire que tu
t'y vas tu vas voir le ministre tu crois
que tu vas voir et non en fait c'est
pire non mais il a même il a même été
jusqu'à dur en fait moi je peux rien
faire voilà je peux rien je peux pas
agir ça me dépasse en fait donc c'est ça
qui est surréaliste est-ce que vous
auriez à lui dire au ministre de
l'Éducation là pas une blague qui a pas
voulu venir ce soir il y aura peut-être
une autre fois enfin moi je lui propose
à papa si vous la semaine prochaine on
réunit plusieurs parents pratique
vous et cetera vous lui racontez et on
voit ce qui va dire ça ce serait pas mal
mais il faut que s'il veut venir pendant
une heure on peut lui laisser une
tribune avec en face de parents qui sont
en difficulté et en face de d'enfants
qui sont harcelés qui leur parle
directement aujourd'hui que les enfants
ils parlent directement qu'il arrête de
voir les recettes et les trucs voilà
c'est très bien ça mais un moment faut
voir les au cas par cas voilà il faut
qu'il déplacent il faut qu'il vienne sur
le terrain on peut lui organiser ça à
papa au lieu de demander un petit billet
c'est rien non non non mais c'est vrai
non non franchement non mais rigole
encore ministre éducation
à mon avis sinon on va rappeler Lionel
jour je pense euh non mais qu'est-ce que
vous auriez à lui dire au ministre de
l'éducation mais qui qui se bouge qui
fasse passer des lois c'est pas juste de
tweeter et de parce que je pense que il
y a beaucoup de choses qui auraient pu
être évité là la petite ligne si elle
avait été entendue dès le départ il y a
le petit Lucas aussi il y a le petit
bout de 10 ans
chaque semaine c'est votre fils qui va
être des scolarisé en fait donc c'est
votre fils qui va rester à la maison à
manger des chips parce qu'ils se remplit
parce qu'il remplit probablement un vide
et émotionnel mais ce qui est dingue
c'est que les autres ils sont toujours
scolarisés etc ce qu'il faut c'est faire
passer une loi un moment donné parce que
c'est le problème du rectorat c'est que
les gosses quand ils sont virés dans le
public les autres en veulent pas non
plus les autres collèges il y a de la
sectorisation donc il faut qu'il y ait
une loi et qu'à un moment donné tous ces
gosses ils aillent dans un truc de
redressement ou je sais pas quoi qu'il
est structures puisque ça existe
et de les dégager voilà il faut une
structure qui accueille
de fermeté une fois les enfants en
difficulté
[Musique]
moi bien tous les harceleurs on va les
mettre dans un centre et ça redressement
la vérité moi tous les harceleurs non
non non non non non tous les artistes
moi j'ouvre le débat aussi ouais
responsabilité des parents moi je vous
dis ça aurait été tapé au portefeuille
désolé et vous allez voir que si tu mets
une amende si tu mets une amende aux
parents et tu leur dis si ton fils il
est harceleur la première fois c'est
1500 balles la deuxième c'est 5000 et la
troisième fois c'est 50
fois exactement
merci allez est-ce que vous avez à dire
à Brigitte Macron
j'aimerais bien être reçu parce que pour
recevoir c'est pas possible il faut pas
attendre qu'il y ait vraiment un drame
pour recevoir les parents bah il y a des
j'ai eu beaucoup de drames parce qu'il y
en a déjà eu assez j'espère que c'est
bien tous les vacances scolaires
j'espère qu'il y en aura pas elle est
capable de vous recevoir parce que j'ai
beaucoup de questions à lui poser et
j'aimerais qu'il y ait vraiment des
solutions parce que là les il faut que
les harceleurs aussi ils ont un suivi
psychologique parce que nous on le vit
on c'est compliqué pour nous mais eux
aussi il faut que les harceleurs ils
aient les mêmes parce que là c'est mon
fils qui est Samsung et tout simplement
vous avez essayé de jouer les parents
on en avait eu une qui a fermé
la maman
dans le nouvel école à Paris
faut continuer à se battre il faut que
Farès retourne à l'école et qu'il soit
tranquille une bonne fois pour toute
merci à vous deux d'avoir été avec nous
on n'hésitera pas à vous recevoir pour
savoir comment ça avance et pour faire
avancer les choses merci beaucoup